E
PROTECTING THE PATRIARCHAL IDEA
THAT WOMEN ARE THE MOST VALUABLE
IS UNIVERSE HOLDERS.
CANDACE OWENS IS THE HOST OF
"CANDACE.
CAN YOU MAKE SENSE OF THAT RANT?
>> ISN'T IT SO SAD WE HAVE TO
TALK ABOUT BASIC BIOLOGY
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU ARE DEALING
WITH SOMEONE WHO IS A
32-YEAR-OLD CONGRESSWOMAN.
I'M SORRY, DID I SAY WOMAN, I
MEANT TO SAY CONGRESS
MENSTRUATING PERSON BECAUSE WERE
NOT ALLOWED TO SAY WOMAN.
SHE NEARLY CRIPPLES HER OWN
ARGUMENT HERE.
HER ARGUMENT IS THE EVIL G.O.P.
IS TAKING AWAY ACTION WOMEN ARE
ALLOWED TO TAKE VIA ABORTION BUT
SHE IS SAYING SOMETHING WORSE,
THE ACTIONS WE ARE ALLOWED TO
TAKE, ARE WE EVEN ALLOWED TO
EXIST ANYMORE?
THIS IS WHAT HER SIDE REPRESENTS
BEAUTY CAN'T EVEN FORMULATE THE
WORD WOMAN BECAUSE YOU FEEL TOO
SCARED, YOU HAVE TO ACCOMMODATE
ALL OF THESE VARIOUS GENDERS.
WOMEN ARE WOMEN, IF YOU CAN'T
ENTER A DEBATE ABOUT ABORTION
AND EVEN IDENTIFY WHAT IT MEANS
TO BE A WOMAN YOU HAVE NO PLACE
IN THAT DEBATE.
>> Brian: YOU LOOK AT THIS
TEXAS LAW AND SHE IMMEDIATELY
SAYS, DOESN'T WANT TO COMMIT TO
AGENDA BUT ALSO BLOW UP THE
FILIBUSTER.
DOES SHE HAVE A CONSTITUENCY?
IS SHE AN ARMY OF ONE WITH A BIG
PROFILE.
DOES SHE SPEAK FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE?
>> IN MY PERSONAL OPINION I
ACTUALLY BELIEVE AOC IS VERY
GOOD FOR THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
AND VERY GOOD FOR CONSERVATIVES.
I THINK SHE SHOWS PEOPLE JUST
HOW RADICAL THE LEFT HAVE
BECOME.
THERE WAS NEVER THIS MUCH
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW RADICAL
THE LEFT IS UNTIL SHE ENTERED
IN.
SHE STARTED STOMPING AROUND.
PEOPLE MAY NOT LIKE HER PLATFORM
BUT I THINK IT IS FOR THE
BETTER.
WHEN SHE SAYS THE PATRIARCHY AND
THE PATRIARCHAL IDEA THAT ALL
THE STUFF WE ARE SAYING,
REDUCING US TO A UTERUS WHILE
NOT RECOGNIZING THAT SHE IS
REDUCING WOMEN TO THE IDEA THAT
WE ARE JUST MENSTRUATING
PERSON'S IS WAY WORSE.
I WOULD RATHER BE A UTERUS THAN
BE REFERRED TO AS DEMONSTRATING
PERSON.
IT'S GOOD FOR OUR SIDE, PEOPLE
NEED TO SEE JUST HOW RADICAL THE
LEFT HAS BECOME.
>> Brian: WE ARE JUST GETTING
THIS AND NOW, LARRY ELDER IS THE
LEADER, GAVIN NEWSOM WILL BE THE
NEXT GOVERNOR, HE'S LEADING THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE AND EVIDENTLY HE
HAD A MAJOR CONFRONTATION IN
LOS ANGELES.
WE'RE JUST GETTING THE TAPE IN.
LET'S JUST WATCH IT TOGETHER.
[SHOUTING]
>> [BLEEP] HANDS OFF ME!
DON'T TOUCH ME AGAIN!
[BLEEP] >> Brian: I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU HAD A MONITOR THERE BUT
THERE ARE A BUNCH OF WHITE
PEOPLE AND A WOMAN IN A MONKEY
MASK TAKING A SWING AT HIS
SECURITY AND
THROWING EGGS AT LARRY ELDER,
CLASSY.
>> YEAH, I HAVE SEEN THIS AND IT
IS ABSOLUTELY INFURIATING.
I KNOW LARRY ELDER, HE'S A
FRIEND AND A MENTOR.
HE'S A MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF MY
FOUNDATION.
IF THIS IS ON THE OTHER SIDE, IF
A WHITE WOMAN WEARING A MONKEY
MASK THROUGH AN EGG AT A BLACK
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE THIS WOULD
BE WALL-TO-WALL COVERAGE.
ACTUALLY THIS MIGHT ACTUALLY
CONSTITUTE A HATE CRIME IN
LOS ANGELES.
WE FIND OUT EXACTLY WHO THIS
WOMAN IS, SHE NEEDS TO BE
ARRESTED AND CHARGES NEED TO BE
BROUGHT, I'M NOT SURE WHY SHE
WAS WEARING THE MONKEY MASK, I
HAVE NO IDEA WHY SHE WAS WEARING
IT BUT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THAT.
>> Brian: THEY ALSO CALLED
LARRY SON AND SOME OF HIS
ENTOURAGE OF SUN AND KEEP IN
MIND THIS IS SOMEONE THEY ARE
TRYING TO LABEL THE BLACKFACE
OF WHITE SUPREMACY WHICH IS
RIDICULOUS ON ITS FACE IN ITS
DEFINITION.
THE GUY GREW UP IN SOUTH-CENTRAL
AND WANTS TO FIX THE STATE THAT
HAS BEEN BROKEN BY THE MOST
INADEQUATE GOVERNOR OUTSIDE OF
THE ONE WE USED TO HAV